hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast from self-seeding
to analysis getting the best out of your
cell based assays presented by dr.
Jessica Vagner Application Specialist
spell handling Eppendorf AG and dr. Eric
funk application specialist pro mega
Germany hi I'm Alexis Cross library and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab birds and
sponsored by Eppendorf for more
information on our sponsor please visit
at the NORTHCOM now let's get started
before you begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click on
the send button well answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problems by clicking on the
answer question box located on the far
left to your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit I'd like
to now introduce our presenters dr.
Jessica Wagner and dr. Eric bunker for a
complete biography on Jessica and Eric
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
Jessica you may now begin your
presentation
Thank You Alexis for the introduction
welcome everyone also from my side and
thank you for joining the webinar today
I want to start
by having a look at the contents for
today's presentation first I will talk
about the general aspects of circuitry
routine and how to increase
reproducibility of your data when
preparing the cells for an essay and
then Eric will take over the next part
and go into detail about optimizing
essay setups and in the end I will touch
the topic of how avoid how to avoid
cryptic contamination that can influence
your essay results here's an overview of
the complete cell culture workflow so
independent of the specific cell type
you're working with these steps are part
of your lab routine for this webinar
Eppendorf and pro mega are joining
forces to optimize your cell based essay
results we will cover the general
aspects like optimal seating techniques
and cultivation conditions and go into
the details of different modes of
detections and essay setup but before we
proceed here comes our first poor
question we are interested in the cell
types you're working with so the
questions is what kind of cells are you
using and you can select all that apply
so the answers are continuous cell lines
stem cells or other primary cells and I
will give you a few seconds to vote and
then we will share the results with you
so please click on the results now
okay so the answers are coming in and
we're going to push the results now for
you
so we see that the majority of you
more than 80% is using continuous
Airlines ten percents about 10% is using
stem cells and almost 14% is you the
using other kinds of primary cells okay
so no matter which cell types you are
working with there are some aspects that
can be considered to increase the
reproducibility and consistency of your
essays or your experiments in general
and this is what we are looking at in
the next chapter
okay so let's have a closer look at this
first experimental step that is so
important the cells eating the
preconditions for getting comparable
results is to seed out the same number
of cells for every negative control
positive control and for every
experimental replicate the more
replicates you include the better for
your statistical analysis of course
variations in seeding cell numbers and
the formation of a bubble during seeding
especially when you work with small 96
wells or smaller wells during feeding
will not only increase standard
deviations it will also make your your
results less reliable when you feel for
instance a multi-well plate with cells
it will take some time until you have
heard all the wells of a plate so you
can use the single channel pipette and
have the cell suspension in a tube or
you can use a multi-channel pipette and
have the cell suspension in some type of
reservoir no matter which tool you use
the longer the seeding process the
higher is the variation and cell number
from one well to the other as you see in
this image here on the upper right the
cells sink towards the bottom of the
tube with time and this sedimentation
goes quite fast within minutes therefore
you need to resuspend or mix the cells
to swirl them up in between to get an
equal number of cells and everywhere
saying that we should keep in mind that
cell culture media tend to foam due to
the high protein content of supplemented
serum air bubbles can hinder cell
attachment in the lower image shown here
you can see how an air bubble hinders
the cells nearby to adhere properly to
the surface so you should avoid harsh
and Hospital to reduce the formation of
air bubbles and also to reduce shear
forces forces which further stresses the
cells
in fact there are a lot of aspects about
pipetting that are often underestimated
pipetting Anderson is an everyday task
and can have a big impact on sericulture
experiments not only the type of liquid
influences the pipetting results also
the pipetting technique plays a role
so when operating the liquid hold the
pipette vertical as seen here on the
left image and immerse the piper tip
only slightly and try to keep a constant
immersion depth if you follow these this
technique you will improve the precision
of the volume that you are pipetting now
have a look how pipetting can can affect
a cell based assay in this graph on the
left you see the results of the cell of
a cell viability assay each column
represents one row of a 96-well plate
the aim was to see an identical number
of cells in each row two rows were left
out for blanks here the cells were
seated with an eight with a manual a
channel pipette from a reservoir after
24 hours the number of viable cells was
determined using a colorimetric si and
in rows one to five you see varying cell
numbers in the wells and therefore high
standard deviations here the user did
not mix the cell suspension between
pipetting each row so the cell
sedimented in the reservoir with time
and in addition the pipette was held in
different angles and highest viewing
aspiration and in rows 6 to 10 you see
the results with mixing the remaining
cells before piping each row aspirated
aspirating at constant height and in
upright position so taken together these
data show that the pipetting technique
has a big influence on the results
besides the technique and the preparing
tool the other thing that can affect
results of an SI are so-called plate
position effects if you work with a
96-well plate the usual volume you use
is 100 to 200 microliters per well
especially during longer incubation
periods evaporation can become a
critical sector with a small volume
especially in the outer worlds because
here the wells are not surrounded by
other wells with warm liquid inside the
evaporation becomes more severe so this
is a phenomenon that we call the edge
effect so the outer wells of the plates
cannot be used because the evaporation
lead to different cellular responses and
what you can do to avoid this edge
effect is to fill the outer worlds only
with medium or PBS to insulate the inner
well if you do that you can avoid this
edge effect but you reduce the number of
usable wells to 60 which is a loss in
capacity of 38% per plate
the Eppendorf cell culture plate has a
surrounding mode that can be filled with
liquid thus the outer wells get
insulated and the evaporation effects
are minimized
and here we measure how effectively the
edge effect is reduced in the epithet
without insulation the evaporation in
standard sericulture plates can go up to
15 almost 20 percent as you can see here
in the upper left image and again if you
think about a volume of 100 to 200
microliters per well and you want to
test maybe different concentration of a
substance over time the evaporation will
influence the concentration of the
substance and the cellular responses are
not comparable anymore in the graph here
on the lower right you see how the
different evaporation rates can affect
proliferation over time so with
insulating the outerwear you ensure
stable conditions throughout the
complete plate in addition to stable
conditions throughout the plate the
conditions for the cells in the co2
incubator should be as stable as
possible every time the door of the
incubator is opened the atmosphere
inside is disturbed temperature and co2
level all influence the cells it's a
good advice to reduce the traffic in and
out of the incubator as much as possibly
possible only open the door when
necessary
and close it as soon as possible some
incubators show temperature overshoot to
reduce the recovery time after door
opening this can harm the cells
especially when you work with sensitive
cells so your incubator should have a
quick recovery of co2 and temperature
without any overshoot as seen here on
the upper right graph especially when
you work with very sensitive cells or
when you work in the lab where many
people are sharing an incubator it can
be a good idea to have separate
incubators for maintenance cultures and
running experiments so you see the cells
for your essay do the treatment
manipulation or whatever you want to do
and put the cells into a separate
incubator for the time of the experiment
your colleague who has to split the
cells or change the medium uses the
other incubator and thus your experiment
is not disturbed by fluctuations of the
inner atmosphere
here on the lower right you see a
screenshot of the menu of the new app
endorsed and experts you - incubator the
red arrow here indicates a door opening
and you see that the curse of co2 and
temperature are dropping monitoring
cultivation parameters and documenting
performance of your incubator are
measures to establish long term
reproducibility of the experiments in
the assays in your lab you can simply
check for door openings or trackback the
performance data to see what might have
influenced your essay this time so
before you start there may be more
complicated troubleshooting of the essay
itself it might be worth looking into
the performance of your incubator
let's have a closer look at the cells in
culture so no matter what you do with a
cell culture it is important to
determine the right time point for a
particular cell type or cell line in
this graphic here you see a typical
growth curve of cells and culture it is
important to not let the cells over grow
until they are in the stationary phase
and do not proliferate any more so the
optimal time point is when the cells are
in their exponential growth phase or
also called log phase and this is when
they are between 70 and 80 percent
confluence plotting the cell growth
curve and determining the population
doubling time for a cell line is
critical for understanding the optimal
seeding density and the optimal cell
concentration range for the routines
have sub coloring of a cell line and
when you launch an experiment it is
important that you can be sure that any
changes in cellular behavior are a
direct response to an experimental
stimulus for example you want to test
how the cells react to the treatment
with a certain substance so you add the
substance to yourselves and see
increased cell death or the
proliferation rate slows down for
example so now to evaluate a direct
correlation between the changes in your
cell culture and the experiment you
performed a constant culture routine is
important so a growth curve provides
information about behavior during
cultivation and thus facilitates the
assessment whether any biological
response can be attributed to the effect
of a tested factor or whether it may
reflect an imbalance within the culture
system
another factor that has often been
ascribed to influence cellular behavior
is the passage number the passage number
is a record of the number of times the
cell culture has been sub cultivated
there are numerous studies giving
evidence that the passage number effects
of cell lines characteristics over time
it has been described that cell lines at
high passage numbers experience
alterations in morphology response to
stimuli growth rates protein expression
transaction efficiency and more so
looking at all this passage number
effects in different cell types
described in the literature the basic
questions in question one can think of
is how many passages are too many and
before we go on I want to hand over this
question to you and start our next poll
so what do you think how many passages
can a cell line be cultured for and the
answers you can click on are not more
than 20 passages 20 to 60 passages up to
100 passages or the passage number has
no influence on the cells so again we
will wait a few seconds and give you the
time to answer until we are showing the
results to you
okay so the answers are starting started
coming in now
all right so we write a couple of
seconds more
okay so we are pushing the result so you
should now see the results for this
question okay so about 53% a few things
that more not more than 20 passages is
is okay around 36% is using the cells
for 20 to 60 passages only 11% is using
up to 100 passages and there's no one
who clicked on the last answer here so
no one of you thinks that the passage
number has no influence on the cells
alright thank you for participating
and so in general we can say keep the
passage number as low as possible
especially primary cells that have a
finite lifespan are prone to genotyping
and phenotypic changes as they adapt to
in vitro culture after a number of
population doublings they will stop
growing
in contrast continues cell lines like
cancer cells or cancer cell lines have
an unlimited lifespan but although they
can proliferate indefinitely also their
genotype and phenotype can change over
time a lot of the well-established and
well characterized cell lines that I
used in laboratories worldwide have been
isolated from their original tissues
decades ago so when you work with a
continuous cell line that has been
isolated from its original tissue like
40 or 50 years ago
it is mostly like it is most likely not
possible to obtain early passages from
the cell line of course but you have to
set a starting point as reference to be
able to obtain reliable results with
this cell line first of all the starting
point should be cells of high quality
the best way to ensure this high quality
is obtaining cells from one of the
established cell banks like the ATCC in
the United States the ECAC see in the UK
other German dias and let here you get
well-documented authenticated cell lines
which serve as the best reference
character for your experiments by
establishing a reference cell stock you
have a constant supply of early passages
from your cell lines now you can
determine the safe passage number for
your cell line of interest by
establishing certain baselines for
example test the cells for the presence
and expression level of a certain
protein or marker monitor the
proliferation rate over time keep an eye
on any changes in cellular morphology by
getting to know yourself you will get an
idea of whether and how does health
change in relation to prolonged
messaging and maybe very simple advice
do not keep cells and kasha that are not
actively used for your assays
so don't passage continuously but rather
it's Deborah's new
says from frozen stock if required and
now I would like to hand over to Eric
from pro mega who will go into detail
about optimizing the setup of your cell
based si
much Jessica and also thanks everyone
for joining this webinar
so on the on this section of the webinar
I would like to talk a little bit about
how these cells that we've learned how
to ideally handle them can actually be
used for in a yeah so to say
experimental setting a so-called
cell-based assay
and primarily I would like to focus on
different key factors which are known to
significantly influence the outcome of
such an assay
first of all I like to talk a little bit
about the most frequently used modes of
detection regarding cell based assays
and also then related to this about
choosing the optimal or a compatible
microtiter plate
I then would like to speak a little bit
about how the actual design of your
essay as well as the self themselves and
finally also the readouts of what you
measure with the essay and last but not
least the timing of your essay can
affect the result of your experiment
if we have a brief look on what
different modes of detections are
frequently used for cell based assays
the first option you have is an
absorbance based assay in an absorbance
based assay you have a light source and
the light produced by that source
travels through a sample and what you
determine is basically the decrease in
signal intensity due to absorption of
light by components within that sample
the second option you have is the
fluorescence based assay and again here
also we have that external light source
which is an excitation source that
produces light of a distinct wavelength
which we also know by the excitation
light and if that light hits a
fluorophore within the sample the
fluorophore will absorb that energy it
will in turn emit some of that energy in
form of light so we have an emission of
light at the longer wavelength
and the third option you have is a
bioluminescence based assay and in
contrast to the other two assays in this
essay we have no external excitation
source however the light that we detect
with our assay is actually produced
directly within the sample in frame of a
continuously occurring chemical reaction
if we now compare the attributes of
these different detection modes we can
nicely see that in fact absorbance based
assays suffer from a very low
sensitivity low signal to background
ratio and a low dynamic range these
parameters are kind of improved in the
fluorescent based assay however you will
get the highest sensitivity in a
bioluminescent
assay and the reason for this is mainly
due to the high background that is
observed in the fluorescent based assay
due to a phenomenon that we know by
autofluorescence and you did that high
background of course we have a decrease
in signal to background ratio and also
the dynamic range is narrowed and if we
look at the bioluminescence assay we
almost have no background and this is in
fact the reason why we can achieve this
high signal to background ratios and
also this wide dynamic range of usually
around 8 to 9 lakh units
also another disadvantage of absorbs
based assets is that there are in
general not applicable to multiplexing
approaches while the fluorescence and
bioluminescence assays can be easily
combined in the multiplexing approach
multiplexing means that you detect two
different parameters using the same
sample by application of two different
assays that you subsequently perform
now that you made up your mind what
detection mode you want to go for you
surely have to select the correct
correct play type which is compatible
with that distinct detection mode in
general for cell based assays you want
that play to be a tissue culture treated
sterile plate and you also wanted to
have a lips to allow for incubation
however then we can distinguish three
different plate types so we have clear
plates black and white plates and the
black and white plates are also
available as solid and clear bottom
plates the advantage of the clear bottom
is that you can visually inspect
yourselves using a microscope however
the disadvantage is that you will lose
some signal at least to some extent
if we perform an absorbance based assay
we usually use a clear plate and
depending on what region of the spectrum
you're looking at you can choose from
different materials what I want to
convey is that you should never use a
clear plate for a luminescence assay and
the reason for this is that you have in
a luminescence based as a continuous
production of light and this light in a
clear plate can travel all the way
across that plate so you would not be
able to track that light two distinct
well within that plate
if we perform a fluorescence based assay
the primary choice is a black plate and
in contrast to what is usually stated
that this is due to a decrease in
crosstalk the actual reason for that
black pigment which is added to the
plastic is that this pigment decreases
the auto fluorescence of the plastic so
the autofluorescence by the plate itself
and this of course decreases the
background in your assay
the primary choice of plate for a
luminescence based assay is a white
plate and in a white plate a brightener
titanium dioxide is added to improve the
reflective properties of these plates
and due to this more of your signal will
be reflected towards your detector so
you could say you kind of have an
amplification of your signal due to that
white color
and also in a luminescent based approach
this white color decreases the well to
world crosstalk
if you use a white asset plate you
should be aware of a phenomenon known as
phosphorescence so it's probably the
worst place to store your plates on the
window bench exposed to sunlight because
then actually some part of your signal
will be related to the plate itself due
to that phosphorescence phenomenon so we
recommend to store these plates in the
dark or to get at least give them some
time at the dark prior to performing
that measurement
slide here I would also like to show you
that there are differences in quality so
a white plate does not unambiguously
equal to a white plate and this has been
shown you by that very simple experiment
where we compare two different plates
and we performed a serial dilution of
elusive arrays in that first column of
that plate and we filled the rest of
that plate with phosphate buffered
saline what you can nicely see is that
in plate a the signal generated in that
first column can actually travel all the
way across that plate but we have a very
high crosstalk while in plate B the
signal is mainly restricted to the side
of its origin and also if we compare the
absolute signal intensities these are
way higher in plate B when compared to
plate A and this shows us or at least to
suggest that the reflective properties
of plate B are higher than in plate a
potentially due to the addition of a
higher amount of that brightener during
the manufacturing process nevertheless
plate B has the properties that you
really want to have in a Cell based
assay because you have a minimal
crosstalk and a high signal output
other factor that you might want to
consider when setting up a cell based
assay is that you really want to reduce
the total amount of steps required to
perform that assay because every step
you add can be a putative source of
error and this is also the reason why
actually all pro mega assays are based
on a fundamental principle the so called
at mix and measure principle this
principle means that we have a single
reagent which we only need to add to
ourselves we briefly mix and then we can
immediately perform the measurement
so due to this reduction in pipetting
steps we not only simplified the assay
for the operator but also make it more
time convenient and again we
significantly reduce the error sources
and therefore increase reproducibility
of the si
that I would like to only briefly touch
is the edge effect that we've already
heard of and which as we learn mainly
affects the outer well of a microtiter
plate and this effect becomes actually
apparent on two different levels the
first of all in the outer wells we have
a higher degree of evaporation of the
medium and therefore we have a
concentration effect of salts that are
within that medium and this
concentration effect can cause changes
in cell growth and cell viability
as a measure to counteract this effect
we can use the specialized plates that
we've heard of or we can only use the
inner wealth of that microtiter plate
and fill the outer wells with pre
equilibrated sterile water or PBS or
medium
the second effect or level that this
effect becomes apparent on is a
temperature effect because you can
imagine that the outer wells of such a
plate will be the wells that respond the
most sensitive towards changes in
temperature which for example occur when
you shuttle that plate from the
incubator to your reading instrument so
our recommendation is that you really
keep temperatures constant over time for
this you could also use your reading
instrument as an incubator at least if
it has a heating function or potentially
also an atmospheric control nevertheless
you should always pre equilibriums that
you use as well as the reader to the
temperature that you actually want to
perform the measurement at
another source of variability in your
assay is the seeding density of your
cells and this is shown by this
experiment where we took cells from a
mystic culture flask and we seeded them
at different densities low medium and
high and then these cells were treated
with a toxic compound and two parameters
the ATP content and caspase recent
activity we're monitored
what you can nicely see is that the
response of these cells to the
respective treatment really defers so
apparently the cells seated at the
lowest density respond more sensitive
towards the treatment with tamoxifen
than the others
additionally not only the seating
density in the microtiter plate but also
the seeding density of your cells in
your stock culture flask can have an
effect on the response of your cells
towards the treatment and this is shown
in this experiment where we used three
different stock culture flasks at three
different cell densities low medium and
high and we use these flasks to seed
cells at an equal density in microtiter
plates again perform the treatment and
s8 the same two parameters and what you
can see that again the cells seated at
the lowest density or from the stock
culture flask of the lowest density
respond more sensitive towards the
treatment within blastn than the others
so our recommendation is that you really
implement standard operating procedures
in your lab regarding your cell culture
to make sure that you have fixed time
points and fixed cell densities that you
use in order to decrease this
variability source
other factor that may be a variability
source in your assay which is also
related to your cells is the metabolic
state of yourself as you can see by this
experiment here where we measure the
consumption of the two commonly added
substrates glucose and glutamine these
substrates actually deplete relatively
fast and on day 2 so after 48 hours
they're actually already nearly gone so
at that time point when the substrates
become limiting for cells the cells have
to adapt and they undergo a metabolic
switch so if you use these cells than
for your assay this might cause some
sort of variability and also going along
with a decrease in this substrate is an
accumulation of metabolic products such
as lactate and glutamate and the
accumulation of lactate is what we
recognized by a change of the medium
color from red to yellow and this
acidification of medium can in fact
cause changes in the viability of
yourself so it's probably not a good
idea to culture yourself over the
weekend and on Monday if you discover a
yellow flask to use these cells than to
perform your assay
but also changes in PA in the other
direction so in the basic region due to
an increase in pH can cause stress for
yourself and this is something that most
frequently happens if you leave your
media bottle in an open state under the
bench for a long time because then your
media will become more basic because you
have that low concentration of co2 in
the atmosphere
so as you see cell viability is really a
key factor in reducing data variability
and you have to perform cell culture in
order to really maintain a high
viability viability assays allow you
also to optimize your cell culture
procedure features for a given cell line
and to really establish a protocol that
preserves a high vir viability so you
can use viability assays for example to
compare different culture media or the
effect of different batches of FCS you
can compare different trypsin ization
times or centrifugation times
centrifugation forces so that you really
optimize your cell culture procedure to
ensure that you work with highly
valuable cells
common markets that I used to check for
viability our reduction of equivalents
you can monitor ATP content or DNA
content which changes due to the
division of cells you can look at the
membrane potential or measure the
activity of two specific enzymes
contrast to checking cell viability you
could also check cytotoxicity which then
is a measure for the relative amount of
dead cells in your cell population and
depending on what marker you choose you
can then also conclude on the respective
mechanism that these cells have died
from common markers are membrane
integrity which gets lost during
cytotoxic processes the release of
lactate dehydrogenase protease
activities can be determined membrane
composition can change during
cytotoxicity and also the decrease in
ATP as well as NADH content is
indicative for cytotoxicity
you can see on this slide is the
reaction of the Firefly luciferase which
is fundamental to most of Pro mega cell
based assays and it is actually the
conversion of the substrate luciferin
into oxy Luciferian and light and for
this the enzyme needs different
cofactors ATP oxygen and magnesium and
we of course we do not use the wild-type
luciferase because this is an enzyme
with low stability we use a modified
recombinant version which we call the
ultra glow recombinant luciferase which
has a highest stability when compared to
wild-type however if you limit a
distinct component of that reaction you
can now for example quantify gene
expression if you limit the luciferase
you can limit ATP and then the ATP will
be delivered by the cells and you
monitor viability and you can also limit
the substrate and then you would use a
pro substrate which is converted to the
substrate by the activity of a specific
enzyme so that in the end the light
output of that reaction correlates with
the activity of that enzyme
our gold standard assay for
determination of cell viability is the
CELTA the glow assay which is a
luminescent assay that quantifies the
amount of ATP in your sample
this essay also follows this app makes a
measure principal so we have a single
reagent which contains all the required
components so this reagent contains all
the components of the luciferase
reaction except the ATP and it contains
a lytic component that will lead to cell
lysis in order to release the cell's ATP
which will then drive the luciferase
reaction so that the light output will
correlate with the amount of ATP and
from this you can conclude on the
viability of yourself
before a cytotoxicity assay is the LDH
release assay in which we primarily
monitor the integrity of the cellular
membrane because if that is lost the
cytosolic lactate dehydrogenase will be
released from the cells into the
supernatant and by coupling now the LDH
reaction to a nother enzymatic reductase
reaction which actually converts a
substrate into luciferin we can now
correlate light output with the amount
of LDH in the supernatant
this asset you can actually use in a in
a kinetic fashion because it is so
sensitive you can collect tiny amounts
of samples so around 2 to 5 microliters
at different time points and you can
either measure these samples directly or
you can even store them at minus 20
degrees and perform the measurement when
you collected all your samples and this
is some data that has been generated
using that assay so cells treated with a
cytotoxic compound and you can see a
nice those and time dependent increase
in the luminescent signal due to an
increase in LDH release
also a hint when using such an essay
regarding LDH release is to use heat in
activated fetal calf serum because FCS
is a considerable source of LDH and by
this you would simply raise your
background and therefore decrease the
sensitivity of the essay
you should be aware of when performing
cytotoxicity measurements is that
cytotoxic markers have a time-dependent
profile and also there are markers which
are really specific for a certain kind
of cell death the for example caspase
activity which goes up very rapidly in
apoptotic cell death is completely
absent in necrotic cell death in
contrast LDH release is high at an early
time point in necrotic diet make cells
dying by necrosis and it is appears very
late in cells dying by apoptosis when
these cells actually become secondary
necrotic and also levels of ATP change
in a different manner so in necrotic
cells ATP levels decline very rapidly
while this is more modis in apoptotic
cells so as you can see the timing of
your essay is an important factor and
this is further emphasized by this
experiment where cells were treated with
turf anodyne and three different
parameters ATP content LDH release and
caspase-3 7 activity whereas 8 at an
early time point you can nicely see that
we have an increase in cytotoxicity and
decrease in viability however if we
would perform the same experiment at a
later time point we in fact see a
decrease in LDH release and a decrease
in caspase activity so that when using a
toxic cytotoxicity marker that is
activity based then we have the problem
that this marker can get degraded or
inactivated and it's really a challenge
to find the right time point to look at
and one strategy to approach this
problem is to perform real-time
measurements
and one opportunity you have is for
example to use this cell tox screen
cytotoxicity assay which is based on a
fluorescent B in a binding die which is
membrane impermeable so that in valuable
cells it will not enter the cell however
is that cell loses the membrane
integrity it will enter in this end of
the cell and bind to DNA and year the
fluorescent signal
so using that assay you can actually
perform real-time measurements of up to
72 hours
on the other hand you also have the
ability to perform real-time
measurements looking at cell viability
and this is one example the real-time
glo empty cell viability assay which is
based on a different lucifer race the so
called nano look lucifer race which
converts Fury amazeen into light and in
this assay the lucifer race as well as a
pro version of Fury Muslim is added to
the cell culture supernatant
and in viable cells the pro substrate is
converted to Fuhrer Amazon and
subsequently to light while this process
cannot take place in depth cells and
similar to that fluorescent cytotoxic
assay with this asset you can also
perform real-time studies up to 72 hours
in order then to identify really the
time points that you want to look at
more closely in future experiments and
with this I'd like to close and hand
over back to Jessica who's going to tell
you a little bit about cryptic
contamination of your cell culture
and thank you Eric so yeah in this last
chapter there are two types of
contamination I would like to talk about
here because both of them are not so
easy to detect and can have dramatic
effects on your essays or other tear
based experiments the first ones are a
micro plasma a special type of bacteria
which are too small to be seen in a
standard light microscope they don't
cause turbidity or color change of the
culture medium like other bacteria and
are therefore often overlooked the other
type of contamination that often goes
undetected are the so called eukaryotic
contamination these are cross
contaminated cell lines or misidentified
cell lines there are estimations that
between 15 and 20 percent of cell lines
used worldwide are either cross
contaminated or misidentified I want to
go a little bit deeper into the topic of
how mycoplasma affect cellular
metabolism by showing you some data from
a study published in 2013 in this study
HeLa cells were infected with mycoplasma
followed by analysis of differential
gene regulation up on different time
points of infection as you can see in
this graph the number of genes that
respond to the micro plasma infection
increases dramatically with time and I
just want to briefly show you an extract
of the list of genes that were
identified I know it's not very good to
read the cellular effects were dramatic
the genes that were deregulated upon
effect infection are associated with
signal transduction pathways immune
responses cell cycle regulation seg
roles and other cellular functions and
this is the reason why cell cultures
need to be tested for micro plasma on a
regular basis if they are tested
positive for micro plasma the infected
cultures should be discarded immediately
to avoid spreading the infection when
you get cultures from another lab or
when the statues of a psychiatry is not
known because you have to wait for the
test results retain the potentially
infected cultures in quarantine for
example in a separate co2 incubator
there are different ways to test for
micro plasma
every method that has its advantages and
disadvantages
the best test method for you depends on
different factors like the access to the
required equipment the number of samples
you need to test and the time you can
wait for the results of the test on our
website Eppendorf comm slash cell
experts you can download a PDF file with
an overview table listing the different
micro plasma test methods their
requirements and their pros and cons and
this hopefully helps you to choose the
best test method for your lab let's come
to the eukaryotic contaminations mr. I
misidentified cell line can develop from
a cross-contamination of two different
cell lines usually this happens by an
accident somewhere during the handling
of the cells so it is a mistake an
aseptic handling miss labeling of
samples and inconsistent nomenclature of
cell lines also contributes to this
phenomenon the cross contamination can
occur when you handle two cell lines at
a time in the laminar flow by accident a
little droplet of the more rapidly
growing cell lines gets into the culture
shown here on this graphic in green
because the pink cells are growing
faster than the green ones with the
following steps of cell culture the pink
cells become sorry you will end up with
a dish of pink cells or a mixture of
both so as soon as two cell types are
mixed up it is very hard to distinguish
those two this process goes fast and it
might go undetected but although the
phenomenon of cross contaminated and
misidentified cell lines has been
recognized for half a century as I
mentioned before still to date we know
that 15 to 20 percent of all cell lines
used or either cross contaminated are
misidentified
misidentified cell lines are used for
studies the scientific as well as
financial implications can be disastrous
here are two examples of contaminated
cell lines and their footprint in the
scientific literature due to
contamination in the 1960s both are
known are now known to be composed of
HeLa cells meaning scientists who
thought they were working on hep-2 or
info on 4:07 were in fact likely
experimenting on HeLa cells nearly 5,800
articles in more than 1,000 journals may
have confused hep-2 with HeLa more than
1300 articles in 271 journals may have
mixed up in foreign for 7 with HeLa all
in all seven thousand plus publications
have been cited roughly two hundred
fifteen fourteen thousand times it was
calculated that more than 700 million
dollar has have been spent on published
work involving just these two
contaminated cell lines and 3.5 billion
dollars spend on subsequent work based
on those papers and these are just two
examples and again I would like to get
some feedback from you and that our next
poll questions so when do you perform
cell line authentication again please
select all answers that apply sorry so
you can choose every time I get a new
cell line into the lab only when I
receive cell lines from a non reliable
source when establishing frozen cells
docks prior to publication or you can
choose I do not authenticate cell lines
so again I will wait a few seconds and
gives you time to answer so we will wait
a few seconds and then we will send the
result and share the results with you so
I see that the first answers are coming
in right now
again we wait a few more seconds
okay so the answers are continuing to
come in
a few seconds more and I'm going to show
the results to you
you
okay so we have
we have like 43 over 23% of you is
performing cell authentication every
time they get a new cell line into the
lab only 7% is performing it when they
receive talent from an unreliable source
28% is authenticating the cells when
establishing them from frozen cells
docks
no one is authenticating the cells prior
to publication and 20% does not
authenticate their cell lines at all
interesting okay thank you for
participating so for those of you who
want to know more about how to
authenticate cell lines and check their
identity here's an overview of the
method commonly used for authenticated
for authenticating human cell lines
short tandem repeat or STR profiling the
analysis of short tandem repeats has
become the standard for intraspecies
identity testing of human cell lines STR
profiling can be performed in-house only
if the required equipment is available
and adequate interpretation of the data
requires quite high expertise and
routine so it can be more advisable to
use a service provider for sale
authentication so we are almost at the
end of the presentation for more
information on cell identity and
reproduce reproducibility please visit
Eppendorf comm flesh cell expert you can
also find information about webinars and
on-site training courses for different
topics including circuitry we do one
on-site training course here in Germany
together with the colleagues from pro
mega before we come to the last slide
here comes the last poll question for
today we would like to ask you for some
feedback so please let us know how do
you rate the content of this webinar
today so the questions you can click on
are very good
good okay or poor thank you for your
feedback and yeah that was it for today
for the presentation and I think we will
soon start the Q&A session now
Thank You Jessica
and Eric for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the answer question
box located on the far left to your
screen demo answer as many questions as
we have time for so let's get started
our first question is
this one is going to be for Jessica how
do you define passage do you consider
the freshly thawed cells as passage zero
I increase the passage number every time
that I trip Sinai's the cells so when
they are freshly thought I I don't
increase the passage number but when I
freeze them I have to trip Sinai's them
before to to detect them from the
surface and then I would increase the
passage number so passage I yeah passage
zero not when they're freshly thought
but yeah every time the the cells see
trypsin or any other detachment solution
I would increase the passage number but
it's people do it differently so the
important thing is that you agree on one
method in your lab so that everyone is
treating the cells the same way with
regards to the passage number and our
next question is going to be for Eric
are your assay is also applicable to 3d
culture
um well primarily our assets were
designed for 2d culture however like the
cell that iglo si we also have in a 3d
culture applicable version and usually
all lytic cells the limiting step in
using these assays for for 3d culture
like steroids is the de lysis of the
cells so you have to achieve a thorough
lysis of yourself and so it does not you
can adapt your essay to 3d culture by
yeah modulating that liza step for
example increasing lysis incubation
times or you could also mechanically
enhance cell lysis so this is something
you can do and for like the LDH glow
assay so where the lactate dehydrogenase
release is measured so such an assay
where you actually use the supernatant
of the cells this is of course then also
applicable to 3d culture yeah because
you don't have to achieve any lysis of
these cells
job Jessica if mycoplasma contamination
is discovered would you recommend or
discourage using a micro plasma
elimination kit if you can replace the
cells I would always say it's better to
discard them immediately and not use one
of these elimination kits
however when they're when you use cells
that are too valuable or that are
irreplaceable for whatever reason you
can try to use these kits
however I would always keep in mind that
they gather the treatment with these
kids may also have an effect on the
cells themselves so I would monitor
other cells very closely when using this
kit and give them some time to recover
and not use them instantly for an essay
after you have done this yeah this micro
plasma elimination treatment
our next question is going to be for
Eric what happens if I use a black plate
for luminescence and a white plate for
fluorescent measurements
okay so you could do that so you can
perform a luminescence measurement using
the black plate of what you have to be
aware of then because the black plate
just does not have this reflective
properties such as a white plate your
absolute signal intensity will decrease
the usually around 1 lakh unit in
magnitude and if you do the other way
around if you perform a fluorescent
measurement using a white plate then of
course because you have these reflective
properties your values will be much
higher with that plate and also your
background will be much higher because
you miss that background decreasing
effect of the black color in of the
black colored plastic
we are getting so many good questions in
today so let's continue on with Jessica
does the evaporation effect occur in our
website sizes for example 6 well 24 well
and 48 well the edge effect mainly
occurs in 96 well plates are smaller
well plates due to the small working
volume for plates with bigger valves and
higher volumes it has not been described
yet as far as I know but there might be
differences depending on the cell type
and experimental setup you are working
with and for this reason you can fill
the inter wells base of all Eppendorf
cell culture plates no matter which size
they are and this way you can prevent
any potential evaporation effect that
might have an impact on your
experimental data
Eric do the substances you use in the
real-time assays have any toxic effect
on the cells
um no they
not at least as I showed you these SS
can be used up to 72 hours so we
performed of course analysis for that
time frame for example we added that
fluorescent dye to cells at different
for different incubation times and we
then for example compared ic50 values
and we did not see any change of these
values so it really seems that these
substances are non toxic to the cells
and it looks like we have time for one
more question so Eric we're going to
stay with you what plate type do you
recommend for multiplexing of a
fluorescent and a luminescent assay
okay well as I said for the second last
question you could do a fluorescent
essay using a white plate also and you
could do a luminescent essay using a
black plate so if you combine a
fluorescent and a luminescent assay you
pretty much could do it both ways
generally for our assets we have a
recommendation included in our technical
manuals however a general rule could be
that you look what signal is the weakest
and then you pick a plate for example if
the luminescence signal is the weakest
you would go for a white plate or the
other way around
thank you again just and Eric do you
have any final comments for our audience
well thank you for joining us today and
thank you for your attention and yeah
have a great day
yeah also I would like to say thank you
and if any further question comes up
later on um feel free to contact us
before we did audience drinks today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration we
would like to thank Jessica Vagner and
Eric bunka for for their time today and
their important research we would also
like to thank elaborates in our sponsor
Eppendorf for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through May of 2019
leverage will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye